hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm officially back back to LA back
to YouTube and back to recording videos
now before I get started with this vlog
there's some things that need to be said
some things that you guys probably have
questions about but first and foremost I
just need to say thank you guys so much
for understanding the amount of support
that's been poured out all across the
internet from other youtubers from fans
from family and friends
from people I I don't even know but knew
Daniel it's really been an amazing time
I mean it's not been a fun time but it's
been incredible to see how much support
has been drawn out of it even people
that didn't really know Daniel or know
his stuff found his stuff and found that
they liked it you know they saw him for
the talent that he had while he was live
and you know it is a tragedy that he's
gone and I've taken the time to accept
that and I've taken the time to address
it in my own way I've taken the time to
process it in my mind because I've been
through grief before obviously and not
saying that this is similar to that each
time that you go through grief it's
different than before but I wanted to
make sure that I confronted it directly
you know I wanted to make sure that I
didn't shy away from it or bottle it up
or do anything like that and that's why
I needed to take a break and I've never
taken a break from YouTube before I've
never taken this long from making videos
it's been absurd to me in my mind it's
been eating away at the back of my mind
slate
you should really probably be recording
something right now people are probably
losing their mind you know but it's been
astonishing to see because you guys
haven't like abandoned me like was one
fear in my mind like you guys haven't
just oh he stopped uploading videos I
just forget about him like I know it's
an irrational fear but it's still
something that as a youtuber it can
happen you know it's just like if I
don't upload videos somehow I think that
everything's gonna come collapsing down
and it's just been really good to see
that you guys have been so behind me and
what we do and you guys have been
watching the videos it
annual Ryan and I made together and the
history that we've had and it's been
really good to see that a lot of our
creations have come to light in this
tragedy and people have seen the talent
that Daniel had you know after all this
happened and so because of that I just
have to say thank you guys so much for
continuing to believe in me in this
crisis and I know that you know you
can't get over someone especially a
close friend being gone after just a
couple weeks it's not something that
just happens like that I've done my best
to address it and I will be seeing a
therapist about it and I'll be handling
it in my own way but I finally feel like
I'm in a good enough place to start
coming back to YouTube and it's not all
going to come back in a big flood I'm
not going to go straight into two videos
a day happy recording because I don't
think I could I need to kind of ease
myself into it and just yesterday I
started feeling a tickle in my throat so
if my voice goes in this video it's not
because I'm about to weep it's because
my voice is kind of starting to go which
is bad timing but I expected to get sick
because usually in times of stress it
can happen and these past two weeks have
been is very stressful but these past
two weeks have also been very beautiful
you know I've gone down in South
Carolina and you know I got C Daniel's
family and friends and I got to see so
many things happening and you know I got
to see all this love for this guy who
was such an important part in my life
and even more so an important part in
their life because I tried to gauge my
response propria because I knew Daniel
very well I I lived with him and I've
known him for about two and a half years
and I've had the delight of working for
him but I didn't see him grow up like
his friends did I didn't see him become
who I met let me become the person who I
met when I did you know I I didn't see
the transition and his family and his
friends especially his family you know
they they lost that the entire history
so in my grief I understand that
comparatively I have to be respectful of
what they they are going through and
just seeing all that was so incredible
and
you know this week I'm going to be doing
one video a day sometime around noon
pacific time or i may be moving to an
eastern upload schedule i have no idea
but to seeing the amount of support is
amazing and this friday i actually have
to go back to south carolina because
they're having this big musical
celebration to really celebrate Daniels
life and Daniel's passion and what he
loved to do and how he loved to do it so
we're gonna have a big happy fun
celebration because the funeral already
happened and it was a very moving
service but it was also very somber and
that's not what Daniel would have wanted
you know and his parents know that like
his parents know that and his parents
are throwing a big party and I really am
looking forward to because it gets to
see a lot of the passion that people had
for his creativity and the spark that he
passed on to a lot of us and when I came
back to LA you know I tell you guys I'm
in a good place and it was hard because
being back in that house alone and just
feeling the emptiness and I will readily
admit when I was trying to sleep I had
quite a few nightmares initially and
sporadically since then and I've had a
few times where I had trouble sleeping
but cleaning the house and being there
and facing it and addressing it was very
important for me because I don't want to
shy away from the things that we had
because those memories I don't want them
to become tainted with the fact that
Daniel has passed away you know I I
don't want to lose what we had together
because holding on to that is what's
very important not holding on to it not
moving on from it but moving on from it
and also remembering the great times
that we had together is very very
important to me because if I'm going to
move on with a spark of his inspiration
and create new and amazing things I need
to remember the times that we had
together
and I never want to be afraid of what we
had together so it was very important
for me to be in that house and to face
it and clean up and do those things that
needed to be done because that's how I
imagined I was going to heal and I am
and I'm currently healing and I'm in a
good place right now and you may be
asking yourself are things gonna be
different you know are the videos gonna
change is a style gonna change and to
some extent maybe like I have no idea I
feel like I'm going to be pretty much
the same guy that I was but also I feel
more motivated to do more creative
things like I've told you guys that I've
wanted to do it for a long time and I
told you guys if it plans to do it it's
just like now it's like like gosh like
what have I been waiting for what are
you doing stop talking about and just do
it already so that's very much my
attitude about things right now but like
I said I'm gonna be easing into it this
week I've got a lot of cool stuff that I
recorded before all this happened in
fact tomorrow will be the next reading
your comments video and it was the last
video that I recorded before all this
happened and you know it very much
captures like the very moment before and
it's important to me because reading
your comment is is very important to me
now because it offers me such a good
interaction with you guys and it offers
me to connect with you guys on a more
individual level which I don't get a lot
these days so I definitely want to keep
doing that every week and try to do that
every Tuesday and after that I have
another video that's coming out
Wednesday that I recorded with Jack
Black of all people like I got to meet
and work with the Jack Black and make a
video with him and I won't tell you all
the details because I'm probably not
supposed to but that's coming out this
Wednesday and that'll be really cool and
then Thursday I'll have something else
planned from a pre-recorded batch and
then you know Selma came out like the
game I've been waiting for four years it
came out and I have to play that there's
so many other games that I have on my
table that I want to play there's so
many things that I want to do but I also
want to make sure
that I'm actually in the good place that
I think I am so over the next few days
I'm gonna be starting recording and I'm
gonna see how I feel from it and I might
engage you know my emotions in going
into that let's see if it's like the
healthy appropriate time that it is and
I'm pretty sure it will be but you never
know if these things so for this next
week it'll be one video a day and then
starting next Monday I'll plan out
another vlog to talk to you guys and
then hopefully we'll be back to two
videos a day and then from then it'll be
another couple weeks before Ryan and
Matt feel up to coming back out here and
I hope by then I have the house
completely cleaned and transformed and
get a dog and a cat and they'll be best
friends and they'll play together and
it'll be so cool but oddly enough it's
harder than I thought to rescue a golden
because there's an interview process
they have to inspect the house they have
to do a whole bunch of things so I might
end up going down to best friends and
I'm society adopting a dog that fits me
from there just because I would really
rather have someone keeping me company
in that house and kind of changing the
energy in the house and just bringing
some happiness into there because
there's a lot of happiness there's a lot
of sad memories you know actually no
there's there's the bad event that
happened but there's not really sad
memories the memories are all happy to
like quote from inside out it's like it
can be happy and sad you know it can be
happy and then it can be sad because of
the context that it is but that didn't
make it not happy when it happened I
loved every moment that I got to spend
with Daniel you know I got I loved every
single thing that I learned from Daniel
and I never want that to be tainted and
I never want to be afraid of that I
always want to be very celebratory of
him and his life and everything that he
did and especially moving forward
because you know Ryan and Matt they're
still here and I really really hope that
they're up to the talent the the
challenge and task of coming back out
here and working again towards making
amazing things for you guys to see
because that's what it was all about
that's all its ever going to be about is
making cool things for you guys to see
and I know that Daniel would have you
know wanted us to keep going in that
regard so just know even though I'm
getting a little teary-eyed here I'm
okay I I feel like I'm okay and I feel
like I'm in a good mindset and though it
won't be a hundred percent happy in the
future you know obviously memories crop
up and I won't be as strong some days as
I am other days but just know that I'm
so happy to be able to do what I do and
entertain you guys and that's so special
and I can't lose that you know I can't
lose that because of what happened and I
won't let it and that's why I'm gonna
take it easy for this week I'm gonna go
back to South Carolina we're gonna
celebrate Daniels life and his passion
and then we're all gonna take a little
piece of that torch I'm going to carry
it on for the rest of our lives and also
I'm gonna keep the pink hair because I
like it it kind of faded a bit but I
think it looks even better now so thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you so much for supporting us I will see
you tomorrow will be the reading your
comments video Wednesday will be the
Jack Black video and then Thursday and
Friday I might pull together highlight
reel my try to work on it like hopefully
I think there might be an animation
ready oh and also very very very
important detail I almost couldn't
possibly imagine why I forgot this there
is now a GoFundMe page to raise money to
help Daniels family pay for the medical
bills funeral expenses and any
miscellaneous things don't feel
obligated to donate because obviously
this is going to help the family and you
know I don't know how much they need I
don't know don't want to be too much so
don't feel obligated to donate but if
you want to chip in just a little bit
there is a link down the description
below that leads to a GoFundMe page is
the official one you'll know because
it's the only one link down there and
all proceeds all proceeds will go to
helping out the kyer family in this
tragedy and I will personally be
donating $10,000 to help them on their
way and hopefully you know make it make
make it so that because the last thing
you want in these tragedies that have to
worry about stupid things like medical
bills and funeral expenses so hopefully
this will go a little way to help them
so just thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you for being here
for me and as always and this is for
real this time as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye